- [Kelly] Well I know that you've talked
about this a billion times,
but my family will actually
kill me if I don't bring it up.
So you're welcome...
- [Juliette] Okay.
- [Kelly] I know people
have to always ask you
about Christmas Vacation, but like, I love
this movie and I know it's...
- How can I be mad at that?
- Well, I'm just saying it's been a minute
so maybe we shouldn't, but I just,
it's one of my favorite.
(audience cheers)
I have never, like, I
spend Christmas with you.
Like, everyone does, like every,
that's an incredible thing.
Like to make so many movie shows, music,
but to have this thing that's
like, so culturally just
in our brains.
And in our, every year,
different generations.
- No, no...
- [Kelly] Very few people
are part of something like that.
- That's right.
- Did you know it was gonna be like that?
- No, I did not.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I did an interview yesterday.
You know, I'm midlife, so I'm
going through many important,
emotional transitional things.
Seizing beautiful, learning how
to appreciate what you have.
And so I get really, (chuckles)
I'm gonna cry.
- Oh you get emotional?
- You know,
Christmas Vacation's so...
It's so touching.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That every year, as a little f...
I was just 15, sorry
I didn't mean to cry...
- That's so cra...
No look, I cry so much on
this show. (audience applauds)
- [Juliette] No...
- They have it here for me.
It's, it's an incredible
thing though, to be
a part of people's lives.
- [Juliette] Oh people.
- Every Christmas...
- And they're like,
you're a part of my family.
People who've lost their
parents or whatever.
What, what it meant to them,
it's a tradition.
- You're a part of
those memories.
- And so what I'm saying is
No...
You can never imagine,
that, is ever gonna happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In a film you do.
I was just 15 years old...
- [Kelly] That's so crazy
young.
- [Juliette] Yeah.
- Wow.
- [Juliette] Chevy Chase
is really supportive.
Johnny Galecki, who of course, who went
on to do Big Bang Theory...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And many other things.
And we were just the new
Griswold kids at that time.
- It was amazing.
Anyway, I had to bring it up
or my family would kill me.